hi everyone my name is brianna frank and
i'm with the ibm cloud team
let's talk about ibm cloud code engine
today many enterprises are benefiting
from using public cloud to consume it
as a service through apis at scale
bringing faster innovation and
flexibility but let me ask you something
are you able to shield your developers
from infrastructure complexity
so they can simply focus on their code
we see that in real life many developers
still struggle with sizing
managing and securing and scaling
virtual machines or kubernetes clusters
so we are taking serverless to the next
level with ibm code engine
now you can get a single deployment
experience whether you're running
containers
building and deploying source code or
submitting large batch workloads to the
ibm cloud
all with a common api user experience
management dashboard and pay-per-use
consumption model
to see how ibm cloud code engine works
let's take a look at a real world
example
airlines run on razer then margins and a
key driver for profitability
is accurate passenger forecasting and
dynamic pricing
an airline is about to overhaul its
pricing strategy by
offering dynamic pricing based on daily
demand
this project architecture will consist
of a highly dynamic website
displaying up-to-date pricing in a
series of long-running batch jobs
to collect operational airline data and
competitor pricing
this data will be fed into a machine
learning model whose output will
determine
the dynamic pricing that is displayed on
the customer facing website
the airline loves the portability and
openness of containers but does not want
to invest in learning complicated
kubernetes concepts
instead they want a serverless platform
to just push code to the cloud
and not have to worry about managing
infrastructure
like everyone in it they have a tight
budget and worry about over provisioning
costly infrastructure
which makes the code engine pay-per-use
model perfect for them
code engine also uses a secure private
network
to handle both their cpu intense batch
jobs
along with their highly scalable web
front end on the same platform
and lastly it uses serverless management
to scale
workloads up or down so they pay only
for what they use
the net result their it team focuses
less on infrastructure and more on
driving the business
to learn more go to the ibm cloud code
engine page
or watch our other videos to see how to
use ibm code engine
thanks for watching if you have
questions
please drop us a line below if you want
to see more videos like this in the
future
please like and subscribe